hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 13 video
so there are a lot of questions raised a
lot of secret organizations teased and
new groups so I'll try to explain those
first careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet so let's
start with the Inhumans first as they
exist on the show there's just like that
small pocket group that the reader has
been collecting and bringing back
we don't know who's running the group we
also have the real shield like those
plots really mirror to each other so you
know Skye's dad whose fate is going to
be decided by this mystery person that's
running the Inhumans group and you have
Lance hunters faith that's going to be
decided by the mystery person that's
running the shield organization just
starting with the Inhumans group so here
you know a couple WTF possibilities it
could be Skye's mom who secretly
survived her Operation Red Heart pretty
much transplanted all of her internal
organs into his body probably replaced a
lot of his blood with her blood too but
the interesting thing that they teased
as part of the sky plot is that you have
enhanced humans people who were modified
by science and then you have the
Inhumans which are kind of like mutants
with the X gene but the X gene and
Inhumans are completely different things
this is actually a good opportunity to
explain the difference between mutants
like x-men characters and Inhumans so a
lot of people feel like Marvel is using
the Inhumans as stand-ins for the x-men
characters just because Fox has the
rights to use the word mutant Marvel
can't use the word mutant so Marvel is
weaving the Inhumans into their
Cinematic Universe the TV shows in the
movies to explain mutant abilities in
the comics the x-gene is something that
evolved separately from the Inhumans
lineage so the Inhumans descend from
creat experiments as you can imagine
that the world is a big place there's
been a lot of interbreeding so you get
people who possess the X gene who are in
humans but not all people with the X
gene can survive the Terrigen mists even
if you're an inhuman and you take in the
mystic and do something really terrible
to you it can severely disfigured you
and your power levels after the fact are
always really variable when someone with
the X gene who already has powers takes
in the Terrigen mists usually what it
does like in the case of Quicksilver is
just take their powers to crazy
uncontrollable levels like Quicksilver
instead of just being able to go super
fast can travel through time so at the
end of the episode when Coulson was
talking about the index to Simmons they
were talking about distinguishing
capital and mutant people from just
normally modified people going back to
that post-credits Inhumans scene -
that's why the reader said you are not
one of us
because Skye's dad used science to
modify himself he's run out of the
comics he uses like a dr. Jekyll mr.
Hyde type formula that gives him
super-strength this whole episode was
about making that distinction who's a
mutant who has these innate abilities
and who's been modified after the fact
it's like a 20 to some odd episode
season so I get why they're taking their
time developing this if this were a
two-hour movie they just like brush over
in a quick montage now moving on to the
real shield so for those that haven't
read the comics there are several secret
organizations inside shield at various
points because a lot of the characters
in the plot lines that they're borrowing
tie-in with secret Warriors Secret
Invasion civil war I think the real
shield as Mac describes it is just the
secret warriors Nick Fury's secret
warriors some of the other big
organizations that are born out of
shield also include hammer strike which
is like a cooperation with the British
government that Lance hunter was part of
in the comics their sword which is more
of like a space-based version of shield
and their Secret Avengers of all those
the most likely ones are Secret Avengers
and secret warriors and what I think is
gonna happen is is I think we'll see
Secret Avengers around Captain America
Civil War like in the movies it'll
require several Avengers to be part of
it so because this is the TV show I
don't think they're doing Secret
Avengers secret warriors is like one
step down from that they're like be
level Secret Avengers kinda but in the
comics those two storylines they're like
big comic book arcs Secret Avengers
they're completely different they're
completely separate secret warriors is
like a comic book event that gets tied
up with Hydra like Nick Fury finds out
that shield has been controlled by Hydra
for a long time and in the wake of
Secret Invasion Dark Reign creates this
splinter group inside shield to do the
work that shield would normally be doing
if you guys have Marvel unlimited you
can totally read secret warriors it's
awesome Daisy Johnson the character that
Skye is playing on the TV show is a big
part of that group Nick Fury actually
trains her to use those gauntlets they
kind of gave her the gauntlets during
the episode they just help her focus her
abilities the big group the secret
warriors ends up fighting against is
Leviathan and
Baron von Strucker so I think just like
based on all the different elements that
we're working with including what's
going on in Avengers age of Ultron
I think secret warriors is like what
this secret shield is regardless of what
they call it I don't know if they'll
actually call it secret warriors on the
show they might give it some other name
so moving into top five moments starting
with a funny one number five we meet
Mays husband or ex-husband this is a lot
of fun like her plot like Mays plot with
her husband is kind of a mirror for the
Fitzsimmons plot if the cavalry can open
up and have fun and be like this really
awesome person with her ex-husband
someone you think she'd normally hate
then certainly Fitz and Simmons can
reconcile and laughing about May it
really does bring them together so I was
really happy with those scenes Fitz and
Simmons one of the best teams on the
show you have to bring them back
together somehow you guys can let me
know whether you agree but you know in
this like Fitz
Simmons battle that they've been having
over Skye and her powers I really feel
like Simmons is coming down like the
antagonist and Fitz feels like the
sympathetic one it's a really weird
light to put Simmons in but but I'm
totally happy with it like there has to
be conflict in the group so a line has
to be drawn in the sand like someone has
to be good cop someone has to be bad cop
it seems like based on the events of
this episode that their relationship was
largely healed not a hundred percent is
especially given what Coulson asked
Simmons to do at the end of the episode
keep secrets from Fitz and everyone else
Bobbi was kind of like the narrator in
the episode we keep secrets for a living
were spies that's what we do moving on
to number four though Skye's dad starts
rounding up people that have been
modified as he explained it he's been
using the index of people that have been
modified to track people that people
that Shield has wronged he wants to
create a group to fight them out in the
open
the Inhumans the people that are
actually in humans are like whoa no put
the brakes on that that ties in a little
bit with their comic book culture in the
comics the Inhumans are a very
xenophobic very insular very private
society attention is the last thing that
they want they do not want the eyeballs
of the world on them so the show is
slowly teasing that out by the time we
get to the Inhumans movie we'll have
like several seasons of shield under the
belt so it'll make sense why we haven't
met the Royals until the movie premieres
because it's like if we have all these
super powerful people how come they
haven't manifested before now because
they don't give a [ __ ] about the cares
of man until it spills into their world
widget now it's kind of starting to just
in terms of the actors I think they
really wanted the
people to feel like b-team so I don't
expect to see them too much more
granting me Te'o is a little bit more of
a celebrity guest star she might come
back on I wasn't a huge fan of her
character though you can make as many
like Lady Deathstrike or Wolverine jokes
as you want and yes the guy with the
sonic ability did you know did remind us
a little bit of Black Bolt but I think
that's just a little we can get the
audience Black Belts ability is way more
complex than just putting people to
sleep with certain sonic frequencies if
he had screamed into that microphone it
would have been like an atom bomb going
off in the city it would have looked
like a giant crater on to number three
Mac captures Lance and takes him to the
real shield this is a pretty big WTF so
let's follow the thread here he captures
Lance doesn't tell Coulson about it
Lance and Mack are both outside of the
base eventually Coulson is gonna be like
hey where these guys go what's going on
Bobbi did tell him that Lance just took
off but Coulson isn't an idiot so he
play as an idea that something's going
on I don't think that bobbi and Mack are
evil they're not working for an evil
team it's not like a group of people
walking around slaughtering people
that's why I think the show is moving
towards secret warriors Nick Fury
territory just because it would dovetail
but the movies really nicely and it
would be a way to keep these characters
keep this Bobbi Mack characters
sympathetic while pitting them against
the team without turning them into
villains and Adrianne Palicki was up to
series regular so so Mockingbird here is
gonna be on the show in a big way for
the rest of the season really what the
show is trying to do is position like
these three different groups you have
like this secret like new shield you
have proper shield with Coulson and then
you have this Inhumans group and they
want all them to feel relatively equal
like none of them are evil organizations
but one is gonna have to be the
antagonist to the other two at any given
time so like the Inhumans really hate
both of the shield groups the secret
shield like the new shield as Mac
describes it it's probably gonna be way
more hardcore about tracking those
people down it'll be like a situation
where the secret shield will go after
the Inhumans and Coulson will have to
take his shield team to get in between
them so even though none of them are
technically evil they'll all be at each
other's throats by the end of the season
which is why I'm really waiting for like
a new villain to surface and the
confusion will just provide a really
nice opportunity for someone really evil
to surface like one of the heads of
Hydra or somebody even crazier I do
think it's possible for Whitehall to
come back and be like the really big bad
of the season even though he's
technically out of commission as far as
we know I really do feel like that would
be an awesome way to close the season
down where you have like Skye's mom who
actually isn't dead surprise surprise
and you have Whitehall whose surprise
surprise isn't dead and they just go at
each other
Deacon Lachman is a great actress so I
was really happy whenever she came out
agents of shield and really bummed when
they killed her off super quick
I think her role on the show is more
complex than we know right now moving on
to number two
Skye starts to figure out her powers
there were a couple minor changes from
the comic books so in the comics Daisy
Johnson is immune to her own abilities
but on the TV show they explained it as
her like redirecting her tremors inside
herself which was like shattering all
her bones the reason they did that is
just to make us emotionally connect with
Skye a little bit more it's the TV show
turning Skye's powers into a metaphor
for what's going on inside her head
that's your dime-store marvel psychology
lesson of the day
to explain the gauntlets she has the
gauntlets in the comics and they just
they they help her focus her abilities
Nick Fury gave them to her on the show
they're a little more practical but what
they'll probably do is they'll just
evolve into the gauntlets of the comics
what I'm really interested to see is
like how many episodes go by before Skye
actually learns to focus her abilities
like is it gonna be the end of the
season or are we gonna see that in the
next couple of episodes I feel like they
wouldn't hang that over our heads for
too long like it's too much fun watching
someone use their powers and enjoying it
and finally my number one WTF moment
Skye's dad is taken back to the Inhumans
base we haven't seen a lot from inside
that place we've only seen like the
reader in flashbacks but based on the
architecture it seems like it's around
the same place where Skye's mom was
captured and died like the places they
lived in China I did think it was
interesting that Skye's dad didn't
totally recognize the reader but maybe
Skye's mother never fully brought him
onto the team because if she was alive
in the flashbacks in like you know
totally normal totally big part of this
society
maybe her association with him was just
in the outside world doesn't it feel
like just like a very cat's in the
cradle thing for them to do to like
bring Deacon Lachman back on the show
like surprise your mother isn't dead
she's alive and like have this big happy
moment for Skye at the end of the season
that just feels like a very TV thing to
do but you guys can let me know if you
agree do you think the Skye's mother is
secretly still alive on the
or she will surface at some point and do
you think that Whitehall is also still
alive so I already explained most of the
Easter eggs in the episode like the real
shield secret warriors type stuff there
was one really cool Easter egg that was
kind of meta the diner that they were
eating in is the pulp fiction diner I
just thought that was kind of funny
because it was a big Sam Jackson movie
Sam Jackson Nick Fury pulp fiction pulp
agents of shield fiction if you guys did
see any other Easter eggs that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments but next week is a
new episode be sure to subscribe to get
my video I'll probably post it Wednesday
morning that's usually when I've been
posting my agents of shield videos in
case you guys haven't seen it there was
like some crazy WTF on the flash last
night you can click here to catch up
with that and you can click here for all
my other agents of shield Inhumans
videos thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight let's all do
the thing
you